on n'a pas fini de parler des impacts du
vol de données personnelles chez
desjardins les demandes d'actions
collectives
l enquête qui se poursuit peut-être
aussi d'éventuels vols d'identité on
verra là chez millions de membres qui
sont touchées on pose une autre thème
spécial sur la protection des données
personnelles ce matin avec martin saint
victor et claude de sarrasin spécialiste
en fraude a donc on a parlé de
desjardins
mais toutes les entreprises sont à
risque ne se sent absolument toutes les
entreprises détiennent de l'information
passe et pas juste l'information sur les
clients qui peut être volé dans bien des
cas ces des entreprises l'information
qui va lécher les entreprises cdse
secrets d'affaires
c'est les listes de prix les listes de
clients les plans les deux vies toutes
sortes d'informations confidentielles
qu'un employé vos volets pour apporter
avec lui chez un compétiteur ou un peu
importe le vendre au plus offrant
souvent ça peut être un sous-traitant
également qui équivalent fin il ya
toutes sortes de possibilités d'endroits
où il ya des vulnérabilités passé la
facilité et on le disait dans la
conférence de presse
autrefois volet l'information
personnelle sur trois millions de
personnes c'était un camion de papier il
ya un avantage à seul pour l'insécurité
cder on pouvait pas se promener avec
ceux aujourd'hui une clé usb et y en a
qui se camoufle un peu partout peut être
utilisé pour transférer le gâteau
facilement et c'est ce qui semble avoir
aidé de go dans ce cas aussi les impacts
sont très très grave va chez la
clientèle qui est touché à ce moment là
martin oui bien sûr parce qu'il ya cette
peur et on se dit est ce que est ce
qu'on peut encore faire confiance à la
marque et c'est pour ça que le travail
tout ce que desjardins va faire aparté
doit faire depuis en fait la semaine
dernière c'est avec transparence
c'est-à-dire que par exemple s'ils font
des audi du système de sécurité qui
doivent informer les mains mais dire
voici ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui
voici les tests qu'on a effectués et
aussi évidemment il faut apprendre je
pense des autres marques qui ont été
touchés parce que l'intel facebook
netflix même radio canada equifax aussi
a été touchée par ce vol de données par
un vol de données dans
l'année dernière donc il faut toujours
apprendre et surpasser la dernière crise
ion veut donc le test de desjardins
tout ce que desjardins va faire c'est
dans la transparence parce qu'on confie
nos données comme ça parce que on n'a
pas le choix on est souvent comme ça
pour faire une transaction
c'est très important et par la suite
donc c'est pas si l'organisation qui
détient nous donne et je parle pas de
desjardins précisément je parle de toute
organisation
on ne sait pas quelle structure est là
pour protéger nos informations il ya
même des entreprises qui doivent pas
avoir de système de détection non plus
n'ont exactement il ya beaucoup
d'organisations qui sont très faibles où
ils vont être très sécurisé par rapport
à l'externe est à voir absolument rien
au point de vue de l' interne où on va
avoir un amalgame où il y aura rien du
tout ni d'un côté ni de l'autre
exact et souvent les administrateurs
ceux ci vont percevoir que sont en
sécurité parce qu'ils ont mis en place
tels logiciels ou tel autre outil mais
c'est pas nécessairement le cas dans la
réalité ça ne protège pas content to
back donc c'est un combat qui est qui et
qui continue et qui est constant dans le
code des jardins je pense que ce qui va
être un des gros élément ça va être la
solution à ce qu'est ce qu'on fait au
point de vue de l'enquêtre va falloir
qu'ils reviennent latule derrière
m'impliquer bien de nous dire bon mais
comme un conte a agi assez long six mois
pour réagir dans une situation comme
ceci moi ça a été la transaction qui a
mis la puce à l'oreille aux policiers de
laval mais pendant toutes ces semaines
là qui nous amène à au mois de mai fin
mai début juin et a dû s'en passer des
choses où il ya plus s'en passer des
choses
exalead harcouët exactement sur le dos
ou parce que je suis à une transition
entre la cybercriminalité et la
criminalité de rue parce qu'on ne sait
ici au québec mme yade et gagne 2 rue
qui font de la cyber il ya toutes sortes
de groupes de crime organisé qui sont
impliqués là-dedans et donc il ya une
transition entre les deux facs a pu tout
simplement à être bon bain voici je me
donne dix mille places puis je te donne
une clé usb il ya de l'information des
jeux souvent c'est comme ça que ça se
passe et j'ai acquis
ddd données de cette façon là dans un
restaurant et je fais que la transaction
en argent comptant avec le type le web
ont fait qu'il y avait pas de but quand
il n'y avait pas de très sophistiqué au
point de vue technologique
ça se fait vraiment dans la rue ou si
c'est un autre aspect de cette
problématique l'oft a fait mais on va
voir comment parce que bon on se rend
compte que les fraudeurs ont peut être
une bonne longueur d'avancé il faut
sécuriser davantage nos systèmes mais
côté organisationnel quelle leçon aux
doit tirer de ce qui s'est produit
en fait ce qui se passait avant ce genre
la sécurité des données c'était c'est l
affaire du bureau de technologies de
l'information d'une compagnie et
maintenant c'est un souci pour tous les
malheurs d'une côté exécutif ça devient
un souci et je pense que le client doit
ou le membre dans le cas de desjardins
doit rester à l'épicentre de toutes les
solutions et côté côté image la
prochaine image qui sera importante
devoir c'est de voir cette employant
menotté et ils devront faire un exemple
de cet employé le pin le punir de
manière adéquate justement pour au moins
montré que écouter ils ont trouvé le
coupable
et voici les conséquences cette image là
serait sera traitement hydro le
mouvement assuré jardin en terminant
vous enseigner mais sarrazin que le
risque de la réputation c'est ce qui est
central dans tout ça absolument c'est
essentiel parce qu'on peut pas parler un
administrateur de nécessairement de
bomba voici il ya telle problématique au
point de vue pratique souvent ce qui va
venir chercher les conseils
d'administration les directions
générales c'est le risque réputationnel
si on 9 février si on essaye d'en
theresa tout finit par se savoir
et c'est à partir de ce moment là qu'on
va avoir de gros problèmes avec la saint
martin saint victor merci à vous deux
est vraiment intéressant merci bien